we all love Jurassic Park but nothing's
perfect yes it's unreasonable to expect
director Steven Spielberg and writers
Michael Crichton and david koepp to know
everything about dinosaurs and
prehistoric eras but the film still
committed a number of easily avoidable
sins and glossed over stuff that should
have been explained more thoroughly
here's a look at some of the dumb things
about Jurassic Park that everyone just
ignored mosquito oh no in the movie park
owner John Hammonds introductory video
shows viewers how Jurassic Park is even
possible a super scientific process that
includes the extraction of dinosaur
blood from mosquitoes preserved in amber
oh what's the dealy where did you come
from from your blood in the movie
scientists stick the needle into the
amber extract the dinosaur blood and
then well you know the rest but in real
life extracting Dino DNA from a sixty
million year old mosquito isn't actually
possible although the amber does
preserve the mosquito nicely time would
still take its toll in the tissue with
decay but let's pause for a second and
imagine that sure you can just glow in a
big old dinosaur from a few drops of
blood so why is Hammond wasting his time
and fortune cloning gigantic killer
reptiles he could be saving lives and
actively improving the world by making
new kidneys or livers or hearts or hold
onto your butts right or even butts
fraudulent fossils Jurassic park's
mosquitoes were unearthed near the
Dominican Republic but in reality it
simply doesn't produce fossils that old
the oldest amber discovered in the
region only dates back 15 million years
sorry Spielberg you still got about 50
million years to go before getting
dinosaur blood now if you want a
wonderful vacation spot which with
coconut drinks cocoa beans and creepy
parrots and awesome baseball players
well
the Dominican Republic is the place for
you man problem plants meanwhile the
movies paleobotanist Ellie Sadler
observes and makes notes about
cretaceous plant life that somehow
flourishes in the park but how the
plants even get there
we know scientists were able to recreate
dinosaurs using the mosquito
how are they able to reproduce and
replicate extinct plants last time we
checked mosquitoes don't need a salad
you don't win friends with salad y'all
win friends with salad
you don't win friends with salad you
don't win friends with darling you don't
win friends with salad besides we all
know that messing around the cloning can
yield unpredictable results that's
that's good chances are pretty good that
the dinosaurs hadn't gotten all agro and
murdery the plants would have no leg to
stand on
Jurassic Park features some scenes in
which Brachiosaurus lean back on their
hind legs to reach higher branches
containing leaves which are poisonous by
the way for them to chew on it looks
pretty cool right great bit of movie
magic happening of course those
dinosaurs weren't actually able to stand
on their hind legs they weren't built to
support themselves that way oh well
anyway
everyone knows dinosaurs had other way
more exciting ways of reaching higher
branches
what can't these movies ever be accurate
man put the frog in the movie the
dinosaur DNA that's extracted from
fossilized mosquitoes is buffed up and
completed with frog DNA to fill in the
missing sequences we use the complete
DNA of a frog the million left hold and
complete this code this raises a number
of critical issues arguably the most
important of which is the fact of
filling in missing genomes with
cross-species DNA isn't really feasible
at all but even when accounting for
suspension of disbelief there are a
number of closer relatives readily
available like birds or crocodiles and
given the choice between a frog or a
crocodile which do you think would be
more likely to do a good dinosaur
impression
too much poop the movie shows dr. Ian
Malcolm stumbling upon a sick
Triceratops heaping mound of doodle
leathers one big pile of while that's
now become an internet meme it's also a
pretty accurate statement although we
don't know much about Triceratops poop
given the size of Tyrannosaurus
droppings archeologists have found it's
likely that the giant pile of Dino do
scene in the movie is way way too big a
real dinosaur wouldn't have been able to
poop out such a gigantic pile even after
a bunch of ice cream thanks for watching
click the looper icon subscribe to our
youtube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]